good evening everybody my name is Trevor
aldenby I'm from Toronto Canada I am
long now member number 378 and this is
are you now or will you ever be a fossil
when I said that word fossil uh each of
you probably had a different treasure
pop into your mind maybe it was
archeopteryx Lucy the Australopithecus
or this marvelous petrified tree
but the truth is fossils are hiding a
little bit of a superpower you see
they're actually naturally occurring
time machines like a gadget they offer
us a magical experience at a
revolutionary price a free window into
the deep past and into the distant
future just holding one in your hand can
encourage you to more deeply consider
our legacies as individuals and as a
species
so what is a fossil anyway well whether
it's a brachia pond or a Brachiosaurus
no real relation fossils are the trace
or bodily remains of plants and animals
from the past that have been mineralized
into rocks
this process can take millions of years
and as a young man I was privileged
enough to be able to explore the tail
end of it in a landscape they don't
often show Canadians in the U.S travel
brochures the Badlands of Montana
in these Badlands as a scientific
research assistant I dug up 75 million
year old dinosaur eggs like the one you
see here turning them from science
objects into art objects by wrapping
them in plaster of Paris for the CT
scanners
and that summer I really understood what
it meant to see nature through multiple
ways of knowing scientific and artistic
that summer in the Badlands gave me a
new lens on life's Evolution and on
myself they hit me right in the Wonder
Zone and if you were to look at the
world for a while through fossil frame
glasses like these what you might notice
is that our relationship to this static
geological process quite a bit more
Dynamic than it first seems
you see just as we're influencing the
Earth's atmosphere and biological
systems we're also influencing its
geological flows and systems of record
with our civilization
the odds of winding up a pristine Mona
Lisa fossil like this albertan
ankylosaur are increasingly unlikely and
that's if we have anything big like an
ankylosaur left to fossilize
you see in order to become a fossil you
have to first go through most of the
original Drake Equation the emergence of
life on a rocky planet near a star but
then there are additional bonus filters
for things like body composition the
speed of your burial the time you've
been left snug and undisturbed and
burial in the right acidic sediment
which give an ocean acidification is
getting harder to ensure
it used to be that taking a long walk of
a short pier in cement shoes was the
best way to get started with
self-fossilization but now we're not so
sure so as we become as Gods as Stuart
brand likes to say influencing the
natural cycles of fossilization what
would it be like to play Medusa
the truth is fossils have been a part of
many human cultures for a very long time
in the cree Canadian painter Kent
monkman's Works fossils are often a
crucial part of the stories and songs
that people share of the land
and in the works of other modern artists
and Architects we see unique vision and
inspiration for how fossilization might
show up in our future or what bodies or
descendants might be leaving behind
it isn't that hard to imagine us leaving
a Cambrian explosion of waste fossils in
our wake forks and filaments fused into
fractal patterns in the Rock like the
trilobites that we're familiar with in
stone
but for the early adopters among us
there is hope scientists and Engineers
are right now cracking the code on
synthetic fossilization turning a
million year process into a long weekend
set on broil in the lab
and it's not hard for me to imagine here
with the long now crowd that a member of
tonight's audience might be the first
contemporary human to be fossilized for
science or for art
we've covered a lot of ground here in
five minutes but next time you hold a
fossil in your hands or look at one in a
museum remember to feel the wonder they
are nature's time machines gateways into
the Art and Science of the long now
thank you